okay what i have for you next i have to
admit
this is a pleasure to watch i am really
enjoying
the entire trump administration just
falling all over itself to try to deny
this blockbuster bombshell story about
donald trump calling
troops who died in combat losers and
suckers i already told you when the
atlantic reported it trump denied it
then the ap corroborated it they kept
denying it fox confirmed it
chaos at fox news cnn now has quadruply
confirmed it
and they have no idea what to do and at
one of those gong show press briefings
friday
trump said both that the source for the
story
doesn't exist and that the sources for
the story are lying so hey hold on
are they real and lying or they don't
exist and are made up by the media
outlets
all four media outlets which is it and
this is amazing and trump
barely able to speak you will hear him
say here three and a half years
it just makes no sense he's making no
sense i've gone after me more than any
president in the united states in
history
in the history of the united states and
it's a shame
it's a shame and despite that we've done
more in the first three and a half years
than any administration
there's been no administration that's
done more when you add it all up there's
been no
despite all of the horrible political
games that have been played
but there's nobody that's been
that's been able to do what i've done
and that includes the great mission act
because what obama passed was a joke
it was a joke and we took it to a level
that nobody thought possible and that
includes accountability
so uh it's a disgrace that somebody's
allowed to
write things like that uh it could have
been you know a lot of times the sources
aren't sources that don't exist and
sometimes the sources are just
people that are disgruntled former
so-called employees
as aaron rupar said on twitter it's a
sort of choose your own adventure here
is it
there are fake sources made up by the
media outlets all four
or is it that these are disgruntled
former employees who are lying
the grief briefing didn't get any better
here trump started to attack his former
chief of staff john kelly on the
suspicion
that john kelly might be the source but
the question trump was asked was
did you disparage american soldiers and
trump
instead of denying it attacks john kelly
and then says
that also the weather was the reason why
he wasn't able to go
to that cemetery in france the fog
prevented him from going to honor the
troops
a claim which has been widely debunked
since and even
able to function in the last number of
months he was not able to function
he was sort of a tough guy by the time
he got
eaten up in this world it's a different
world than he was used to
he was unable to function and i told him
john you're going to have to go
please give me a letter of resignation
and we did that and now he goes out and
badmouths now there are people that are
jealous there are people that are upset
that they're not here anymore
there are people we've done an
incredible job the virus came in and now
we're doing an incredible job again
we're going to build it up bigger than
it was
before the virus came in but i don't
know that it was him i haven't seen that
i mean i see anonymous but it could have
been a guy like a john kelly
because he was because just so you
understand
he was a very
you look at some of his news conferences
what happened to him he got eaten alive
he was unable to handle the pressure of
this job this job
was a tough job mark meadows doing a
great job
but kelly was unable to do that and as
far as that day i mean we have
so much proof as to going to
the we i went to paris and the environs
and i was all set to go they had a
rainstorm the likes of which you've
rarely seen
the fog was so great it was it was as
dense as i've ever seen just unable
to stick to any topic ever then trump
said again that the atlantic story is a
hoax
ignoring of course that at this point it
had been corroborated by the ap
and fox news and after this briefing by
cnn
as well you spoke earlier about the
atlantic story and you
referenced the number of administration
officials who have come out
to support here we have 11 people i was
just told
i was just we have 11 people there is
nobody that feels
more strongly about our soldiers our
wounded warriors
are soldiers that died in war then i do
it's a hoax just like the fake dossier
was a hoax
just like the russia russia russia was a
hoax it was a total hoax
no collusion just like so many other
things
it's a hoax and you'll hear more of
these things
totally unrelated as we get closer and
closer to election
the magazine is a failing magazine and
nobody called me nobody called me from
the magazine said you have a comment
about it no they just write whatever
they want to write
because they figure you can't get sued
you can't get sued but it's very
it's a very hard bringing lawsuit of
course the other things trump mentions
also aren't hoaxes the dossier was real
with lots of accurate things and many
things that are
still unconfirmed the russia thing was
not a hoax dozens were arrested the
mueller report couldn't exonerate trump
the senate select report pointed out
that a lot of the allegations were true
so none of them were hoaxes
and then trump wrapping up hilariously
by assailing the reporters in the room
as children asking terrible questions
and then
bizarrely thanking them for their
presence biden
getting asked questions
that it really meant for a child to
answer anybody could answer
and i look at the level of question that
you people ask i mean honestly it's
disgraceful
so i want to thank you all very much we
appreciate it
and we're doing very well we're very
very proud of what's happened with
respect to the economy i i just love
that your questions are childish
you people are disgraceful thank you
very much for being here at my press
briefing which couldn't exist without
you actually being here this is a man
falling apart and this was only part of
the press briefing i want to kind of
separate it into stuff related to the
soldier's story
and then other things that happened at
the rally i'm sorry
that's a freudian slip other things that
happened at the briefing
right after this because there is much
more to discuss
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now
and thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized care
from the comfort of your home it's a
service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable go
to steadymd.com
pacman to take the free quiz see which
doctor is right for you
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me is a really
perfect fit for me and my medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video